We're here with the two best guests
any party could ever want, Dana Carvey
and Dana, David Spade.
Dana Spade.
Dana Spade, Dana Spade is here.
Stay on the cue cards, come on.
My brother from another mother, look at that guy.
That's right.
Well, next up, we have this weird story
of a stolen Sasquatch.
The AP is reporting that a 7-foot tall Sasquatch
made of metal was stolen off
a font lawn in Michigan.
It's described as rusty brown
and sharp around the edges.
Authorities say there was a white van
with tinted windows spotted nearby
and whoever snatched this squatch,
that sounds dirty.
Yeah.
Must be really good.
Now that-
'Cause they had to use a bolt cutter.
Guys, what do you think, who's doing this?
Stupid crime.
I'm kinda into supernatural stuff.
I think Sasquatch decided one day
to simply walk away.
I think the bolt cutters weren't even involved.
I think that Sasquatch turned-
A little tired of being chained up.
Turned, yeah, turned into something real.
I mean, I have a 30-foot kind of toy Lochness monster
in my pool-
Oh, wow.
So I like, yeah.
Nessie?
No, I just made that up.
I love his Nessie.
It is Nessie, though, Drew, you're right.
Maybe it's the guy's desperate
for an anniversary gift for his wife
or something like that.
Nothing woman likes more than a rusty,
old, beat up, 700-pound dirty Sasquatch.
None of this phases me except for the white van.
Yeah, right.
That's the thing that scars me most in this story
is the white van with the tinted windows.
I think OJ.
Whenever I see a white van I think OJ.
I'm not saying he had anything to do with it.
I just think OJ.
I'm so scared of vans.
I've always wanted to see a Sasquatch.
I got close once.
It was a Bear week in Province Town.
There we go, there we go.
Kidding, kidding.
I like the dogs.
Kidding.
Thank you, Ross.
Hey, finally, you guys, here's a question.
Have you ever crushed super hard
on someone who's not even real?
I'll explain.
"Metro" reports it's very common
to have an intense crush on a fictional character,
even if that character is a cartoon
and I have bravely said here on the show
that my first crush was on Aladdin.
Okay, I will stand by it
with that open vest, oh, my God.
Well, experts say it is totally normally,
just don't let it get out of hand.
I don't, they say it's normal to have
a crush on a cartoon?
Is this true?
Have you guys ever had crushes on fictional characters?
Well, hmm.
I did on "The Incredibles."
That lady in "The Incredibles had
a bit of a badonka donk, you remember that?
Yeah, and like Holly Hunter did her voice.
Yeah, 100% hot.
Oh, yeah, Holly Hunter.
Yeah.
Listen, I'm one of "The Incredibles."
That's right.
Holly Hunter.
I never heard your alcoholly Hunter.
Oh, haven't you heard it?
She goes, you have no excuse,
have you no schooling.
What are you guys talking about?
That's from "Broadcast News."
I actually asked this question once
of Mike Meyers as Garth.
I said to Wayne, "Did you ever find Bugs Bunny attractive
when he put on a dress and played a girl bunny.
Of course.
So this is 30 years ago we were talking
about this kind of stuff.
Wow.
Bugs Bunny in a dress, yeah.
And also Jessica Rabbit.
Even I was like okay, girl,
I got it.
Yeah, way out of my league, Jessica Rabbit.
Mine is Darth Vader.
What?
Ever since I was a kid I really found Vader hot.
I think he's so sexy.
Maybe there's dad issues there.
I think, I think.
There's something.
There's a lot.
I also, every once is a while a mask can be hot.
You don't know what's going on under there.
It's a ton of mystery.
He just will wrap you up in that cape
and you can, I had a dream
where I used to like press the buttons trying
to escape and then the cloak would come closing in
and I'd look up and camera would pan
and there would be Darth
and I felt something.
(audience applauding)
You know, that is too funny.
I like your answer better.
I did have sort of,
I just had an admiration for Chewbacca
and I called him up once
and said, "I just wanna hang out as friends,"
and all I heard on the phone was (imitating Chewbacca).
So, anyway.
Well, David Spade and Dana Carvey, oh,
all your characters and you
are just everything and I love you guys so much
and check out their podcast, "Fly on the Wall,"
right now so-
On the wall.
So you can find out "Fly on the Wall" information
from two brilliant gentlemen.
I'm actually on the episode this Wednesday.
Thank you again for having to the party.
The episodes Wednesday.
Thank you for putting art out into the world.
You guys are great.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)